so i have the same green rectangle up
here and down here
and what i want to do is measure its
width but we're going to measure its
width
in two different ways up here we're
going to measure its width
in terms of how many of these paper
clips wide the rectangle
is and down here we're going to measure
its width
in terms of how many centimeters wide
this rectangle is
so let's start on top pause the video
how many paper clips wide
is this rectangle all right
now let's do this together we can see
that the rectangle
starts right over here and it ends
right over here on the right if we're
thinking about its width
and so we have one two three
four five six seven
eight nine ten paper clips
so this rectangle is we could say ten
paper clips paper clips
wide now if we want to measure it in
terms of centimeters we would do the
same thing but we would use this ruler
let me do this in a different color
so the left edge is there the right edge
is right over there
and it looks like this rectangle is also
one
two three four five
centimeters wide five
centimeters wide so notice
10 the same rectangle has the same width
it's
10 paper clips wide and it's 5
centimeters wide
so its width is more paper clips than
centimeters is one way to think about it
now based on that what is a larger unit
of measurement
the paper clip at least these paper
clips or the centimeter
pause the video think about that
well you might just see it naturally
where you if you just look at
a centimeter right over here it looks
wider than a paper clip
but you could also tell that by looking
at the measurement we needed
more paper clips to cover the width of
this rectangle than we needed
centimeters
and so because we needed more paper
paper clips
that means that this is a smaller unit
of measure because we needed
more of them so this is a smaller
unit of measure
or maybe actually i should make the
arrow point right over here the paper
clip
is the smaller unit of measure and then
the centimeter
is the larger unit
of measure we needed fewer centimeters
to make up the width of the rectangle
than
paper clips so the centimeter is larger
and you can see that visually if you
just look at
that width compared to that width it's
clear that a centimeter
is wider than this paperclip